the Raiders shook off the Antonio Brown
madness and took care of the Denver
Broncos with virtual ease michael silver
my compadre from the NFL media group
wrote a great piece on nfl.com and he
adds a little bit of voice to that how
are you Mike great rich how are you I'm
doing well what was it like in that
locker room after the game last night in
Oakland you know I think there was just
a general sense of relief in that
organization and specifically when it
came to Derek Carr he just told me look
I'm so glad it's over and he said I
don't want to make it sound like I'm
crushing at Tonio brown as a person but
you know it was a lot and he came out
three game looking more fiery than I'd
ever seen him just you know kind of like
staring through people went out in the
field and then played like it from the
start I and you know this is the direct
car we saw in 2016 well-protected had a
running game to go to throwing with
authority making quick decisions and I
you know doing big things in Oakland so
car is a sigh of relief there a little
bit well what what did happen Michael
that that caused Antonio Brown to
celebrate getting released there because
you look at this team and as car said
after the game it would have been
incredible to have him as the one
receiver at Tyrell Williams looked like
a 1 receiver he could have been number
two like the juju Smith Schuster in a
way what what happened to have him
celebrate that well I think one problem
is that we keep talking about this as
though Antonio Brown is rational and is
making decisions in his best interest
like you or I would try to do or most
people I you know and I'm concerned I
obviously am NOT a mental health
professional but you know I've talked to
enough people who've known him and know
him and it's around him that you know
this this may be bigger than football
it's either that or he's one of the
great con artists of our time but even
then if this was some grand plan to get
out of Oakland
to New England I don't get that either
you're going from a place where they let
you do a lot of things and let you get
away with a lot of things before finally
paying enough to a place where clearly
they're not going to do that and I again
that that makes no sense to me either
but but I just think this is a guy who
has reached a point in the last few
months where he spiraled to the place
that if you tell him he has to do
something he's not only defy it but
blurting out his you know his defiance
on social media
he's hypersensitive and he's very very
unpredictable and and I will say this
you know Jon Gruden mike Mayock they
have to run the organization to coach
the other 52 in retrospect I think both
men would say we probably enabled them
too much or we at least we should have
drawn a line earlier this is ridiculous
I there at Conor I think more than
anyone went out of his way to try to
make this work he all offseason through
with Antonio Brown reached out to him
tried to bond with him and even as it
got bad at the end I think there at cars
nature is to try to make everything work
out and and have people get along and I
honestly think he was hurt by it and to
his credit he channeled it into
something pretty good at least in a week
what Michael silver of the NFL Media
Group my compadre from there in the
Honda insider report let's focus in on
our former colleague mike Mayock a
little bit here Mike because you just
said that even Mike would think that
perhaps that they they let let it go too
long and he's the one that is now in the
crosshairs if you will of a Twitterverse
or a 21st century attention span we're
brown in the span of four hours went
from a complete
cast off and loser of 31 million
guaranteed dollars to a patriot that was
being lauded as the missing piece within
a span of one afternoon Mike is being it
might be Mike's being criticized for
that all in all out stuff as alienating
Antonio Brennan that he shouldn't have
done that knowing what you know from
behind the scenes how do you take that
criticism of Mike well first of all Mike
was as you know great at what he did at
NFL Network and universally respected in
our world I didn't have to leave was
lewd by Jon Gruden to take that job and
and 40 and John knew the deal John runs
everything but Mike was going to be his
top personnel guy with the GM title but
Mike's a very headstrong guy and you
know someone who I know Revere's Bill
Belichick and likes the way he does
things and so I think his inclination is
to be an authoritarian and be
no-nonsense which i think is generally a
good thing in you know when you're
trying to change the culture on a
football team they got to a point with
Antonio Brown probably because John is
in full control where they were trying
to just think yeah he's being weird
right now about the hell that a defeat
but let's just get him on the field
because he's so good and we can get
through this and finally I think they
did the good cop bad cop thing which was
smart and by design it have might be the
be the bad cop but then you know you
can't get to a point where a player is
threatening a general manager in front
of everybody else in the organization
and some days it doesn't edible or any
organization so I you know I'm Sherman
like if he were in full control would
have drawn a line much earlier but yeah
people who are saying well now now he's
the missing teeth now it's all good
there's no way it works out in doing
good unless as I said before he was just
pulling a con the whole time which I
find really hard to believe
I think what's much more likely to
happen is Bill Belichick who absolutely
is going to draw a line at some point
and significantly Tom Brady who wants
his receivers to be where they're
supposed to be and we know Antonio Brown
you know has a penchant for freelancing
that that worked out pretty well in
Pittsburgh I think those guys are going
to say hey dude
we'll do it this way here we can't and
we're now asking ourselves to imagine
that an Tonio brown is going to respond
to that by saying okay coach okay Tom
I'll fall in line rather than say
surreptitiously posting a phone call on
his Instagram or a five-letter or you
know saw the lyrics invoking the devil
that seemed to point to his general
manager I give this four weeks
Michael silver you give it four weeks
because it looks like again Belichick is
is doing his usual removal of the oxygen
from a flammable situation and Brady's
taken a min and you know their their
their selfie buddies and game one is
gonna be in Miami where we all know
Miami is is not you know on the same
level and then Game three is home
against the Jets I mean where where does
the blowout happen tonio Brown and you
just wanted to wear whatever helmet you
wanted and do whatever you wanted to
come and go as you please and you know
just not ever have anyone question you
or find you why would you want to leave
Oakland and thirty 1 billion dollars
Terran seed to go there just to win a
couple more games I mean that doesn't
make sense to be either so yeah okay
maybe now bills gonna you know pull some
great thing but again we're trying to
imagine a world where a Antonio Brown
can flip that switch I not about how
he's acting or has acted suggests to me
that he
so I would just say to all of them vaya
con Dios and be careful because they've
done something that is incredible for
two decades that you know seems
inconceivable and there have been times
like after the Malcolm Butler benching a
couple of years ago with the Super Bowl
where it seemed like this is all finally
going to end you've got a 42 year old
quarterback who you know whose greatness
is one of the pillars of this 42 who by
the way is going to be a free agent
after the season it seems like he wanted
it to be that way I and Gronk is gone
Josh Gordon is one mistake or you know
just like I guess he steps away on his
own technically last time but Josh
Gordon could be gone in any moment and
now you're putting that Tonio Braun in
the room I think we may look back and
say how did this all unravel I don't
think the Antonio Brown signing is going
to age well in history last question for
you Michael silver is our poll question
ask it of him Cris Brockman go for it
please mi GAF tur week one which team
should be most concerned bears Browns
Falcons Steelers such a tough one
because I did pick the Browns to win the
AFC so you know I took a gut punch there
but I'm gonna I they have so much talent
I'll stick with the by the way curious
that the Miami Dolphins are not on there
you know I had such high hopes for them
going into the season I said which i
agree with you i thought you know
atlanta yeah they were up 23 in the
superbowl a few years ago and looked
like they were about to throw a parade
that unraveled they got back to the
playoffs the next year and I came very
close to beating the Eagles and then the
Eagles were long last year was a step
back but they had injuries to blame they
made some changes after the season and
you know pretty big organizational
changes though they kept the coaches GM
and quarterback I there's a lot of
pressure there and for
them to come out I can see them losing
at Minnesota but to come out and be down
you know that that much that early and
never really be competitive that that
concerns me it does to their home for
Philly on Sunday night at Indiana
Indianapolis home for Tennessee at
Houston I mean it I'm not I'm a little
concern right there thanks for call mike
drive safe great stuff out of out of you
a week one will chat down a line thanks
a lot every day you got a at Mike
Silver's how you could follow him on
Twitter for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app